Well mr.
Evans can you remember an amusing instant
incident that happened while you were on
the bridge. Yes i can. Richard. There
you know there is no toilets there we
go to get down to go to you mightn't
have time but the time you got down.
So we'd have to take a brown paper bag or
a sheet of paper and if you want to do
a crap. Well you know to hide in the bracing
or in the chords and do what you want
to do and then when you're done what
you wanted to do yet come out and
throw it on the leaf
side that is the way the
wind was blowing to the other side
but this particular day. My boss
jemima your and mr.
Hepworth were walking across. And that must
have been somebody out there that short
this day. And when they'd
finished. What they were doing
instead of intro on the bag to wended
its allow it. A tour it up again as
the weather side and it blew over
back onto the roadway and fell down as mr.
Hip. Well and miss them. You know
walking across and flattened out like
a pancake on the roadway. It wasn't
there anyway. You know you're not
allowed to go down to the toilet while
you were on working on the arch. No you
couldn't bear it. You wouldn't have
time to go down. Richard that it was
a thing that you had to do everything when
you were up aloft. And there was no sort
of toilet arrangements up there at all.
No toilets whatsoever. Only the blokes
working down below. They've probably had
a toilet but as far as working on the
on the heights of the bridge to take
and do for yourself. Wherever you
could you know i think the change
a bit since those days.
Thank you very much.